[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 vous l'avez
remarqué ce soir nous ne sommes pas sur
l'habituel plateau de TV 78 mais nous
sommes sur la scène du Théâtre du prisme
à Élancourt le théâtre lance sa nouvelle
programmation de l'année 2023 2024 c'est
ce soir avec la soirée entracte à 20h30
nous découvrirons ensemble les nouveaux
les nouveaux spectacles à découvrir au
prisme ce sera à 20h30 je le répète nous
sommes le mercredi 7 juin voici le
programme de ce soir du théâtre de
l'humour ou encore des acrobaties dans
cette émission nous reviendrons sur le
programme culturel de l'année 2023 2024
reprises d'Élancourt quels sont les
spectacles à venir on fait le point avec
le directeur du théâtre
favoriser les échanges entre les
personnes en situation de handicap et
les personnes valides c'est l'objectif
de la nuit du handicap l'événement
national se déroule ce samedi et
Versailles fait partie des 35 communes
de France à participer on en parle avec
nos invités et ce soir on parlera
également d'éducation dans votre 7 8
notre journaliste Régine ralech revient
avec sa chronique édital qu'elle s'est
intéressée à la méthode Montessori quel
est le principe les réponses dans cette
émission et dans cette émission
également la Semaine de la santé
sexuelle les collégiens des Yvelines et
des Hauts-de-Seine qui visitent le
château de Versailles et bien évidemment
les films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
au cinéma tout ça en fin d'émission mais
avant je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera dès de
nouveau au rendez-vous dans les Yvelines
côté température ça grimpe comptez 19
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles et 18 degrés à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi il fera toujours beau
temps au niveau des températures il fera
en moyenne 26 à 27 degrés et demain nous
fêterons la Saint-Médard le point
maintenant sur les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous c'est ninja
bonsoir alors on commence ces
informations du jour avec la réforme des
retraites et où il l'abrogation de la
retraite à 64 ans ne sera pas discuté
dans l'hémicycle c'est ce qu'a annoncé
Yaël Braun Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ce matin chez nos
confrères de BFM TV l'article 1 du
projet de loi du groupe Lio pour liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire sera
déclaré irrecevable il devait être
discuté en séance Jeudi 8 juin le groupe
Lio regroupe des députés
issus du centre droit et des socialistes
le groupe et le projet de loi ont obtenu
l'appui de la nupes du rassemblement
national et de certains députés LR elle
s'appuie la loi s'appuie sur l'article
40 de la Constitution qui empêche les
parlementaires de créer une charge
financière pour l'État par le biais
d'une proposition de loi ou d'un
amendement sans la compenser un peu de
sport à présent Céline vous nous emmener
à Verneuil-sur-Seine ou un baptême a eu
lieu dans l'après-midi celui d'un
terrain de football et les plus
exactement le terrain d'honneur du stade
municipal son nouveau nom Matteo
Guendouzi le footballeur international
qui porte actuellement le maillot de
l'Olympique de Marseille alors Mathilde
vous allez sans doute me demander
pourquoi sur des terres plutôt acquises
au PSG on donne un terrain le nom d'un
joueur d'un joueur marseillais et bien
c'est tout simplement parce que Mateo
gaine Douzi est un titi du PSG il est
passé par le centre de formation du club
champion de France en signant sa
première licence avec le PSG à 6 ans
cette année à l'école de foot puissante
de préformation et à Verneuil-sur-Seine
se trouve le collège dans lequel son
scolarisés les jeunes joueurs rajoutons
à cela qu'il est né à Poissy on l'écoute
au micro de Grégory canalet et William
Morel j'y suis resté pendant trois à
trois années donc j'ai fait ma cinquième
quatrième troisième ici au collège et
bah sur ces terrains c'est là où on
s'entraînait pareil pendant trois
saisons avec la avec la préformation
donc moi ça avait ça fait quoi 9 10 ans
maintenant donc pas mal de très bons
souvenirs qui qui reviennent c'est rare
d'avoir d'avoir quelque chose à son nom
encore plus un stade de football donc
voilà je remercie toutes les personnes
qui ont été derrière moi et voilà qui
qui vous poussait depuis le depuis le
plus jeune âge et c'est pas une voilà
c'est c'est ça devient récompenser aussi
le travail que j'ai fait depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant
toujours en football Céline vous voulez
nous partager une information qui nous
est parvenue en fin d'après-midi elle
concerne la situation du club de
football de Poissy alors effectivement
Mathilde une réunion s'est tenue hier à
l'invitation de la mer Sandrine Dos
Santos avec le conseil d'administration
de l'AS Poissy et d'anciens membres du
club de football la municipalité
attendait d'avoir les informations
exactes concernant la situation
financière du club après plusieurs
heures d'échanges Poissy constatent et
je cite le communiqué de très nombreuses
défaillances au sein du club la mère de
la ville a reconnu la passion tenace est
sincère des instances dirigeantes mais
aujourd'hui elle attend un projet pour
la formation au football de tous les
piciaqués et si les moyens sont au
rendez-vous un projet sportif de haut
niveau elle a demandé au club de
transmettre d'ici à la mi-juin des
garanties financières de partenaires
prêts à s'engager pour rappel Poissy et
convoqué devant la DNCG contre leur
financier du football français le 4
juillet pour défendre sa cause et éviter
une délégation régionale 1 on poursuit
avec un mot sur Roland Garros Céline
notamment avec une yvelinoise qui jouait
aujourd'hui en tennis fauteuil simple
dame et oui Pauline déroulait d'été en
quart de finale du tournoi cet
après-midi la 18e mondiale licencié à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux affronté pas moins
que la numéro 1 mondiale de cette
difficile face à diète de Groot Pauline
déroulette s'incline donc en car pour
son premier Roland Garros et on passe à
notre image du jour c'était cet
après-midi ce matin pardon à l'île de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines via
l'occasion du programme voile olympique
voile pour tous le dériveur olympique
470 a été mise à l'honneur organisée par
l'association 470 France l'événement
s'est déroulé ce mercredi 7 juin à la
base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines tout au long
de la journée une vingtaine de jeunes a
pu embarquer aux côtés d'experts pour
apprendre à naviguer le but faire goûter
au plaisir de la navigation en double
donc on espère que tous ceux qui auront
navigué sur sur nos bateaux regardons
avec plus de
connaissances et plus d'intérêt les
régat qui seront retransmises à la
télévision avec un peu moins de toiles
que c'est concurrents il permet une
utilisation par tous les temps et
s'adresse à tous les publics pour
retrouver ce bateau rendez-vous au JO
2024 et ainsi pouvoir s'identifier à nos
champions nationaux avec un changement
puisque les équipes seront mixtes et je
le disais en début d'émission Céline ce
soir nous sommes au prisme d'Élancourt
et c'est pour une raison bien
particulière et oui de l'humour du
théâtre des accrobaties le prisme
d'Élancourt présente sa nouvelle saison
ce soir avec son entracte les
spectateurs pourront découvrir tout au
long de la saison Lionel Astier avec
Victoria Abril Bruno Salomon sur scène
avec Davy Sardou Thierry Beccaro
Marianne James pour ne citer que à
l'animation notre directeur de
l'information Patrice Carmaux début de
la soirée 20h30 à retrouver sur notre
antenne et bien merci beaucoup c'est
ninja pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information ou une image qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
alors voilà nous sommes bien installés
sur la scène du prisme à Élancourt nous
sommes en compagnie de Thomas perron
Arnaud bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de ce théâtre avec vous on va
parler de cette nouvelle saison
culturelle qui arrive pour l'année 2023
2024 première question comment est-ce
qu'elle a été imaginée pensée cette
programmation culturelle
en rapport avec la saison qui vient de
se passer où on avait effectivement
changé un peu le paradigme sur sur la
programmation on était plutôt sur du one
man show des comédies du théâtre de la
musique donc on est on s'est basé un peu
sur le c'était Matic là puisque ça très
très bien fonctionné puisqu'on a été sur
un taux de remplissage de 82% ce qui est
quand même plutôt très bien post covid
donc on s'est basé effectivement sur sur
cette thématique là alors après nous on
est aussi dépendant des tourneurs des
productions en fonction des spectacles
qui sont proposés donc voilà donc
effectivement on fait un choix par
rapport à ce qu'on nous propose on
imaginant que ça puisse plaire à notre
public ce qui a priori était le cas la
saison dernière alors dans les grands
rendez-vous qui nous attendent j'ai noté
tap Factory c'est un show avec cette
personne ce sera le 7 octobre je vous
propose de regarder un extrait on en
parle tout de suite après
[Musique]
alors on le voit bien sur ces images
c'est un véritable show Factory il y a
une histoire derrière où c'est
simplement qui a été créé et qui a
tourné dans le monde entier et c'est
très chapelet ce qu'on fait c'est où il
y a un mélange de claquettes c'est très
très basé sur les claquettes la
percussion voilà donc c'est
un spectacle je publie en fait c'est
vraiment on a décidé de commencer la
saison avec ce spectacle là pour que les
gens puissent venir en famille en fait
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment l'idée que
ça soit quelque chose d'assez attractif
assez percutant un peu onirique avec un
très beau décor des très belles lumières
ça fait partie de notre métier le
spectacle les lumières le décor le son
voilà donc on a vraiment choisi de
commencer la saison avec ce spectacle là
en pensant qu'effectivement ça ça
regrouperait les familles ce qui est
aussi
une de nos missions c'est aussi de
pouvoir proposer des spectacles à des
prix attractifs pour les familles quand
on sort à deux trois quatre on essaie de
faire en sorte que le prix soit quand
même raisonnable voilà un autre
rendez-vous Marianne James elle est
connue notamment pour avoir participé à
la nouvelle star c'est une autrice une
interprète comment est-ce que vous avez
fait pour la faire venir aux prises
alors avant la nouvelle star moi je la
connaissais plutôt pour artiste parce
que j'ai eu un contrôle de nouvelles ça
mais effectivement je la connaissais
plus en tant qu'artiste sur son premier
sur son premier spectacle
personnage pétillant intéressant
très grande chanteuse et du coup là on
est sur un spectacle pareil qui est un
peu interactif puisqu'en fait c'est un
spectacle qui est en même temps musical
qui est drôle où il y a effectivement
cette interaction avec le public où elle
fait chanter des gens elle fait monter
des gens sur scène donc
l'idée quand même dans le spectacle
vivant c'est de pouvoir échanger c'est
quand même la base de du spectacle
vivant c'est quand même surtout ça et là
pour le coup ça fonctionne très bien
puisqu'effectivement c'est vraiment dans
un échange permanent avec le public
voilà et comment comment la on la repéré
parce que parce qu'elle est connue et
qu'effectivement elle a à la notoriété
qui la précède et puis elle a cette
espèce de d'énergie
ultra positive qui est le monde du
spectacle c'est aussi on a le droit
aussi d'avoir des spectacles de de cet
ordre là c'est à dire qu'il soit léger
intéressant voilà il faut faire des des
spectacles légers en ce moment c'est ça
que vous retenez ce que je retiens c'est
que ce que je retiens c'est que dans le
dans le théâtre et notamment dans le
nôtre on essaie de d'avoir une
proposition artistique qui soit assez
large ça veut dire qu'on peut faire
aussi bien de la comique ou du théâtre
avec des choses un peu plus classiques
un peu plus où il y a peut-être un peu
plus de réflexion mais ça n'empêche pas
effectivement d'avoir des choses qui
soient un peu plus populaires au sens
noble du terme et qui soit accessible au
plus grand nombre ça c'est quand même
l'idée principale du théâtre de le
prisme en fait c'est de pouvoir attirer
des gens pour se faire plaisir et en
fait absolument et de faire en sorte que
des gens pour qui le théâtre l'ensemble
le théâtre soit pas forcément quelque
chose ou tiens je vais à l'hôtel nous
l'idée c'est de faire venir des gens
dans notre théâtre qui aurait jamais
l'idée d'y aller avant voilà
James justement qui qui met du baume au
cœur qui fait rire je vous propose de
regarder un extrait de son spectacle en
1 il faut des poumons c'est l'usine qui
donne de l'air et ça remonte par la
trachée ça traverse le vibrateur là le
larynx qui émet un son pas très beau
d'ailleurs ça fait un peu ça les cordes
vocales comme ça et au dessus magie
magie 3e chose troisième étage de la
fusée le masque raisonnateur
l'amplificateur toute la tête et tout ça
ça fait une voix alors oui on n'est pas
tous égaux devant la voie l'humanité
nous a offert Maria Callas mais aussi
Carla Bruni
[Musique]
je reconnais cette reculence on connaît
son humour un peu incisif on touche
aussi certainement avec avec Artus un
public un peu plus jeune et c'est la
première fois on va faire un spectacle
le dimanche en fin d'après-midi d'accord
donc ça c'est une première mais parce
que ça ça pouvait pas se faire autrement
par rapport aux routines des des
productions donc voilà et on s'est dit
bah oui tiens dimanche à 18h ça peut
être sympa d'aller voir un spectacle
plutôt que de rester je sais pas à la
maison ou regarder la télé ou je sais
pas peut-être aller à la pêche sur ça
voilà donc l'idée c'était aussi de de
changer on essaie de on essaie
systématiquement changer de s'améliorer
de réfléchir à des nouveaux des nouveaux
projets des nouvelles choses au théâtre
en fait on travaille dans la culture on
essaie de d'être toujours à peu près
curseur et de d'essayer de changer les
choses alors on va parler de tête
justement quelques pièces seront jouées
forcément durant cette saison culturelle
il y a notamment changé l'eau des fleurs
qui a été nommé au Molière 2022 avec
l'actrice Caroline Rochefort qui a reçu
le titre de révélation féminine voilà et
donc là pour le coup quand on parlait de
la programmation on aussi du théâtre
parce que en fait une fois de plus quand
on fait par exemple Artus on va aussi
essayer de vendre aux gens qui viennent
voir Arthus on a aussi du théâtre
effectivement changer le des fleurs
c'est un livre qui a été vendu à 850 000
ou 900 000 exemplaires la pièce a été
montée après après le livre
effectivement avec une comment dire à
très très bon retour au niveau de la
presse et des spectateurs donc
effectivement aussi on a on a aussi ce
type de pièce qui alors on est plus du
tout effectivement dans dans l'humour
des choses comme ça on a des choses un
peu plus un peu plus fine ou il y a un
peu plus de réflexion et en même temps
et en même temps ça fait partie de notre
mission aussi de pouvoir aussi avoir des
choses de cet ordre là en fait voilà il
y aura aussi des des comédies notamment
au scalpel et une autre drôle de genre
avec Lionel Astier et Victoria Abril
alors là effectivement on est sur
quelque chose de complètement différent
mais en même temps dans le genre il y a
même si c'est une comédie il y a quand
même une réflexion derrière sur sur
l'identité enfin des choses comme ça
donc on peut faire de la comédie avec du
sens et quand les acteurs sont bons le
message habituellement passe assez
facilement et notamment par le biais du
rire donc voilà donc c'est ça c'est
effectivement c'est une pièce qui a qui
est à la fois drôle et en même temps
qu'il y a du sens alors le programme
culturel est riche puisque vous avez
aussi de la musique avec notamment
Chimène Badi qui va venir célébrer les
60 ans de la disparition d'Édith Piaf
absolument et on connaît pareil on
connaît la chanteuse on connaît ça ça
prestance sa façon d'interpréter les
choses elle est c'est une grande grande
fan de de d'Édith Piaf
effectivement c'était l'occasion du
rendre hommage on a un très très beau
spectacle un peu minimaliste avec des
très beaux décors mais par contre quand
vous avez des très bons chanteurs de de
cet ordre là ça suffit presque à eux
donc et on est ravis d'accueillir tous
ces artistes là parce qu'en fait
globalement l'idée aussi sur le prisme
c'est de pouvoir avoir une programmation
qu'on pourra retrouver à Paris avec des
facilités d'accès des prix raisonnables
en terme de de prix du billet quels sont
les prix justement quelle est la
fourchette si les gens prennent la carte
prise mais ils peuvent avoir sur
certains spectacles qui peuvent payer 12
euros sur d'autres qui peuvent payer 22
23 24 en tout cas c'est vrai que le côté
attractif de du prix du billet une fois
de plus par rapport aux familles des
choses comme ça et puis en plus on a la
facilité d'accès on a un bar on a de la
restauration on a des expositions on est
on est sur quelque chose qui est un peu
plus vivant et un peu plus un peu
différent de juste de la consommation
très consensus on est aussi dans
l'échange avec les gens avec notre
public on connaît qui nous connaissent
vous avez des habitués toujours des
fidèles effectivement nous notre
objectif c'est de recevoir les gens au
mieux de ce qu'on peut c'est pour ça que
chaque année on essaie d'avoir des
projets un peu nouveau on travaille avec
des artistes locaux pour les pour les
expositions puisque effectivement on a
un panel assez large dans la dans la
région et notamment sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'artistes
donc voilà donc systématiquement on
essaie déjà de travailler avec les
artistes locaux comme ce soir avec avec
Adrien clartryo qui est qui sont des
artistes de la région mais qui sont qui
sont à niveau exceptionnel voilà donc en
gros on a tout ce qu'il faut ici pour
faire bien et voir peut-être mieux qu'à
Paris et dans des conditions techniques
d'accueil du public largement meilleur
souvent que les salles parisiennes et
bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et puis
surtout d'avoir de nous avoir accueilli
sur cette scène théâtre à Élancourt donc
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur la
nouvelle saison culturelle aux prismes
ne manquez pas la retransmission de la
soirée entracte c'est à 20h30 sur notre
antenne on en parlait en début
d'émission samedi prochain le 10 juin
c'est la nuit du handicap partout en
France et parmi les 35 communes qui
participent Versailles au programme des
ateliers des jeux ou encore du sport de
15h30 à 22h dans les jardins de la
mairie de Versailles pour en parler avec
nous Marion trop de Salt responsable des
bénévoles pour l'association La Nuit du
handicap à Versailles bonsoir et vous
êtes accompagné de Xavier de scène ville
l'organisateur de cet événement à
Versailles bonsoir alors première
question pourquoi c'est important pour
vous pour cette sixième édition de
revenir et de recréer un événement la
nuit du handicap à Versailles
bien parce qu'on on est là dans la
continuité ça fait 6 ans qu'on organise
ce magnifique événement le covid n'a pas
eu raison de nous puisqu'on a réussi à
nouveau à relancer ce spectacle et cette
animation dès 2021 et donc vous l'avez
dit 36 villes aujourd'hui dans en France
entière et donc les Yvelines il y en a
36 apparemment on est la 36e d'accord et
donc et donc Versailles les Yvelines
voulaient voler s'associer et on a été
une des premières villes aussi à
animer à faire que cette cette fête soit
une véritable rencontre entre les
personnes porteuses handicap et le grand
public alors quels sont les personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont concernés
par cet événement toutes j'imagine tous
les handicaps en fait tout est toutes
les toutes les personnes surtout qui
veulent venir faire la fête parce que
c'est avant tout un une journée de
festive une journée joyeuse et que
chacun puisse montrer ses talents et
c'est vraiment l'objet de notre de notre
rendez-vous c'est faire que la rencontre
ait lieu entre les personnes qui ont
entre toutes les personnes qui ont des
Talents qu'elles soient handicapées ou
non il y aura de la danse de la musique
du sport quels seront les activités que
vous allez proposer samedi alors du coup
on fait venir des personnes artistes qui
seront sur scène et qui présenteront il
y aura du théâtre de l'handicap Barret
joué par des jeunes autistes d'accord
il y a beaucoup d'activités comme ça qui
vont sur scène qui vont se succéder et
puis il y a des activités sur la dans
les jardins de la mairie de Versailles
où on peut essayer le handy
les gelettes il y a on fait venir le du
Cécifoot et il y a aussi de la cécie
pétanque et en fait tout ça c'est créer
une activité pour pour créer la
rencontre et le but aussi c'est de se
mettre dans la peau d'une personne en
situation de handicap et montrer que
tout le monde peut faire du sport
finalement j'imagine oui c'est ça c'est
se rendre compte des difficultés qu'on
peut avoir faire ouvrir les yeux le cœur
et l'esprit aux personnes et pour pour
comprendre les difficultés des personnes
handicapées que le handicap soit visible
ou invisible et pourquoi pas dans la rue
enfin allaitendre la main à une personne
connaissant un peu les difficultés
qu'elle peut avoir c'est plus facile de
briser les clichés les préjugés qu'on
peut avoir sur sur l'handicap et les
personnes en situation d'handicap par ce
biais là le sport la musique la danse
bah oui tout à fait parce que tout le
monde peut faire du sport en fait qu'on
soit handicapé ou pas et d'ailleurs ils
sont très forts parce que faire du
basket ou du rugby en fauteuil roulant
du volet assis c'est assez sportif et
nous quand on s'y essaye et ben on se
fait battre à pas de couture et voilà et
c'est chouette de voir ça ça
on est plein d'humilité de enfin c'est
vraiment une journée enfin des partages
qu'on fait dans la joie et les
rencontres sont vraiment belles
je veux bien ajouter aussi que c'est
aussi une avant tout c'est la fête la
rencontre est une fête donc on est là
pour s'amuser et donc par des activités
ou autre mais il va y avoir un spectre
des spectacles mais il va y avoir aussi
un cabaret il va y avoir un une
guinguette donc chaque année pendant 5
ans 100% de sourire à la fin de cette
journée et ça c'est une voilà c'était la
joie il a réussi pour tout le monde
alors justement quel est votre meilleur
souvenir finalement de cette journée de
cette nuit du handicap parce que vous en
avez organisé plusieurs précédents
est-ce que vous avez un meilleur
souvenir
alors déjà on a un livre d'or on aurait
dû venir avec pour vous dire tout ce
qu'on a recueilli comme comme sensation
comme expression de cette joie qui anime
tout un chacun et
puis oui dans un souvenir extraordinaire
c'est un flash Bob qu'on a organisé et
qu'on a commencé à avec ceux qui avaient
répété à 5 10 15 20 personnes on a fini
avec plusieurs centaines de gens qui
étaient là comme ils étaient avec quoi
ils sont venus et ça c'était à une
c'était merveilleux il y aura aussi un
flash-bob cette année vous réitérer
assurance succès Marion trop de sol
votre meilleur souvenir oui alors moi je
parlerai de de d'une rencontre en fait
cette nuit de handicap elle est aussi là
pour aller vers les personnes touchées
par le handicap les familles qui sont
touchées par le handicap et de se rendre
compte que des personnes sont très
seules et finalement qui qui reviennent
avec joie l'année précédente et l'année
suivante pardon et que vraiment c'est
touchant et c'est fait pour ça
rompre la solitude aussi des personnes
l'année dernière vous aviez accueilli
1300 personnes environ il me semble
cette année vous attendez combien de
personnes et est-ce que la nuit du
handicap ça devient un rendez-vous à
Versailles
alors on est oui la nuit du handicap à
Versailles ça y est c'est inscrit au
programme chaque année
et
et oui enfin c'est
ça devient un rendez-vous et est-ce que
vous attendez combien de personnes vous
attendez finalement cette année on était
oui à 1300 l'année dernière et là on a
préparé 1800 tickets il faut être parce
qu'on essaie de compter chaque année
voilà et on espère toujours être plus
nombreux et alors comment ça se passe
concrètement les infos pratiques si on
veut venir si on veut y participer on
vient et ensuite programme
ça démarrera à 15h30 et on finit par un
bal jusqu'à 22h et le programme français
est affiché il est aussi dans beaucoup
de médias de réseaux sociaux etc et donc
voilà on a une programmation certes
beaucoup moins ambitieuse que vous
monsieur mais on a quand même du théâtre
mais on a quand même de la musique on a
comme des voilà d'autres activités mais
100% joyeuse déjà réunir de la danse de
la musique et du sport sur une même
journée et c'est déjà à beau challenge
bien merci beaucoup en tout cas Marion
trop de saule tu es Xavier de scène
ville d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors je le rappelle la nuit de handicap
ce sera ce samedi 10 juin dans les
jardins de la mairie de Versailles toute
cette semaine c'est aussi la Semaine de
la santé sexuelle à cette occasion le
département des Yvelines organisé
vendredi dernier une table ronde pour
présenter les actions des centres de
santé sexuelle la journaliste Sandrine
arcizey marraine de la team 78 et
animatrice de la Table Ronde nous
présente les enjeux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était hyper intéressant de
de partager
d'informer aussi et bien toutes les
personnes qui l'existaient des centres
de santé sexuelle qu'il y en avait 8
dans les Yvelines et qui les personnes
pouvaient s'y rendre gratuitement en
plus de ça et que les jeunes aussi
pouvaient être informés
déculpabiliser entre guillemets pouvoir
parler
naturellement simplement
ce que j'ai compris là aujourd'hui et
que je n'étais vraiment pas du tout au
courant c'est que les jeunes en moyenne
d'âge dix ans tu es déjà avait déjà vu
un film pornographique là c'est quand
même 10 ans c'est très jeune et après ce
que ça en découle en fait ce que ça fait
par la suite ça ça se voit ça m'a un peu
interloqué quand même
[Musique]
lorsqu'on est au collège au lycée c'est
bien tout de suite aller voir
l'infirmière par exemple si on a un
souci parce que elle l'infirmière elle
sera déjà anonymement dire ben voilà va
voir telle personne ou tel médecin ou
voilà un centre de santé sexuelle par
exemple
voilà pour t'informer pour régler il y a
un problème s'il y a un problème parler
aussi la parole c'est hyper hyper
important quand on est jeune
[Musique]
les parents ont vraiment un rôle à jouer
dans l'éducation sexuelle de leurs
enfants par la parole comme on vient de
le dire par les informer alors c'est
vrai qu'on l'a dit aussi là il y a des
âges à respecter on va pas parler à un
enfant de la même façon lorsqu'il a 7
ans ou lorsqu'il a 15 ans et puis même
un peu plus âgé donc il faut adapter
c'est pas évident pour les parents
d'adapter la parole d'adapter les
conseils à son enfant mais je pense que
c'est hyper important d'ouvrir le
dialogue avec des mots simples et de se
faire aider
[Musique]
on poursuit cette émission avec la
chronique de Régine ralech et du Talk
Régine bonsoir alors aujourd'hui vous
nous parlez de pédagogie alternative et
de parentalité c'est à dire
je ne vais pas parler de formation ni
d'école comme je le fais habituellement
mais je vais parler du d'un podcast qui
aborde plusieurs aspects d'éducation et
de la part
et le but c'est de faire découvrir ou
redécouvrir des des pédagogies
éducatives qui placent les enfants au
cœur de l'apprentissage alors juste
avant je vous propose de regarder un
petit extrait du de demain c'est un
podcast qui vise à mettre en avant des
pratiques éducatives innovantes qui
soient plus adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui au monde de demain donc
toutes les semaines on publie deux
épisodes une interview avec des
personnalités inspirantes du monde de
l'éducation et un épisode court qui sont
appelés les pauses éducatifs de Sylvie
et en plateau on a justement l'honneur
d'accueillir l'une des fondatrices de la
pote du podcast Sylvie d'esclub bonsoir
alors donc vous avez cofondé le podcast
on va en parler dans quelques instants
mais vous êtes aussi connu pour avoir
fondé le premier lycée Montessori à
Bailly alors on le rappelle juste la
méthode Montessori elle a été créée par
Maria Montessori en 1907 elle se base
sur plusieurs principes comme la
confiance en soi l'autonomie ou encore
l'apprentissage par l'expérimentation
alors Sylvie d'escape vous avez été
passionné par ce sujet donc vous avez
donc décidé de créer une école pour vos
enfants en 1991 et au fur et à mesure
des années l'école s'est agrandi pour
couvrir tous les cycles jusqu'à la
terminale aujourd'hui si on se retrouve
c'est parce qu'en 2020 vous êtes lancé
en toute autre défi donc celui de créer
un podcast avec votre fille Stéphanie
donc ma première question va de soi
pourquoi avoir créé un podcast pour
parler d'éducation
parce que moi mon but depuis de très
nombreuses années c'est de diffuser le
plus possible ces pédagogies différentes
pour que ça puisse profiter au plus
grand nombre d'enfants possibles donc
j'ai écrit beaucoup de livres mais après
l'évidence était le podcast puisqu'en
fait le podcast c'est gratuit on peut
écouter ça n'importe quand tout le monde
peut l'écouter donc c'est une façon de
donner le plus d'informations possibles
aux parents aux enseignants des
personnes qui s'occupent d'enfant ou qui
sont intéressés par ce domaine et ça
c'était une évidence pour moi surtout
que c'est c'est un outil qui est de plus
en plus utilisé par tous et
particulièrement par les par les jeunes
couples quand les jeunes enfants et qui
qui se posent beaucoup de questions sur
l'éducation sur la parentalité et pour
moi c'était le meilleur moyen de
diffuser toute cette expérience et puis
aussi tout ce qui est découvert
aujourd'hui par les par les plus grands
spécialistes en fait alors qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve dans ce podcast j'imagine
des interviews des échanges ça dure
combien de temps alors ce podcast il a
deux épisodes par semaine donc il y a un
épisode où c'est ma fille Stéphanie qui
interview les plus grands spécialistes
de l'éducation de la parentalité dans
tous les domaines de depuis la naissance
jusqu'aux adolescents et puis moi qui
fait un épisode par semaine ou je donne
des activités pour les parents des des
je parle des pédagogies différentes je
parle du bilinguisme tous les sujets qui
peuvent aussi aider les parents et les
éducateurs et donc on le comprend bien
dans l'intuité l'intitulé les adultes de
demain ça s'adresse aux parents
j'imagine mais est-ce que ça peut
s'adresser aussi à des psychologues des
professionnels oui en fait ça s'adresse
à tous les spécialistes de l'enfance du
bébé à l'adolescent les adultes de
demain parce que c'est une phrase de
Maria Montessori qui disait l'enfant
elle adulte de demain donc si on veut un
joli monde demain il faut s'occuper des
enfants pour avoir des adultes
bienveillants bien dans leur peau etc et
alors ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que vous parlez de parentalité c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui sont souvent destinés aux
femmes parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
maternité est-ce que vous parlez aussi
du rôle du père qui est un rôle qui a
beaucoup évolué ces dernières années à
travers les épisodes ah oui bien sûr on
a eu des épisodes sur le congé de
paternité on a interviewé plusieurs
papas qui ont aussi arrêté travaillé qui
ont des podcasts très connus aussi
justement sur la parentalité parce que
c'est eux qui font l'école à la maison
on parle oui de tout le monde même j'ai
fait un épisode sur le rôle des
grands-mères puisque je suis grand-mère
maintenant donc on essaye d'aborder tous
les sujets autour de l'enfant tous les
sujets possibles pour offrir le meilleur
aux enfants est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des premiers retours du coup sur tous
ces épisodes ah bah oui parce que on a
fait beaucoup d'épisodes donc on a cinq
sur cinq sur Apple podcast on a on est
on est assez apprécié on est un des
premiers podcasts en éducation et
parentalité en France et d'ailleurs vous
avez aussi récemment lancé un autre
podcast donc bébé arrive donc cette
fois-ci qui est plus axé sur la
grossesse et les premiers mois du bébé
est-ce que vous pensez aussi que
justement dans le paysage médiatique
aujourd'hui qui me manque un peu ce
terrain d'expression on peut parler de
la grossesse on entend de plus en plus
de femmes qui qui parlent en fait de ce
qu'elles ont pu traverser ou des bonheur
et autres est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui le podcast c'est un moyen
aussi de pouvoir parler de tous ces
sujets mais oui je pense aussi que c'est
très intéressant parce que justement on
peut l'écouter tout le temps on peut
interviewer des spécialistes avec des
avis pas toujours les mêmes mais
justement je pense que les parents
peuvent faire leur choix là-dessus et
que c'est plus pratique de d'écouter un
podcast pendant 20 minutes une
demi-heure que de lire un livre de je ne
sais combien de pages bon comme je vous
dis c'est gratuit aussi et je pense
qu'il faut en parler il y a beaucoup de
sujets en fait qui sont pas vraiment
abordés et je vois aujourd'hui bon ma
fille qui n'est pas là parce qu'elle
vient d'avoir un bébé alors c'est elle
interviews et ben je peux vous dire que
que elle en a besoin quoi c'est pas
facile il y a plein de questions qu'on
se pose et aujourd'hui il y a tellement
de choses sur internet que on sait plus
qui croire qui à quel saint se vouer
donc je pense que c'est bien d'être allé
vers les plus grands spécialistes elle a
été allée dans la France entière
rencontrer puisqu'elle était enceinte ça
l'intéressait à double double raison et
elle a rencontré vraiment des plus
grands spécialistes même pour les pères
pour pour la grossesse pour les premiers
mois pour l'accouchement pour etc donc
je pense que c'est vraiment nécessaire
moi d'entendre tout ça c'est pas facile
mais merci beaucoup Sylvie des clubs
d'avoir répondu à nos questions pour nos
téléspectateurs qui seraient intéressés
par le podcast les adultes de demain
chaque mardi un nouvel épisode est
disponible sur toutes les plateformes et
sur votre site internet les adultes de
demain.com et le jeudi aussi c'est vrai
il y a deux épisodes par semaine
direction le château de Versailles à
présent lundi dernier environ 3000
collégiens des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine ont été ont visité le
château de Versailles initiative portée
par les deux départements et par
l'établissement public du château pour
cette 5e édition les arts étaient à
l'honneur nous avons pu suivre les
élèves du collège La Fosse aux dames des
Clayes-sous-Bois regardez
écrire et déclamer son poème laissons
les Muses nous guider la nature nous
inspirait et l'épreuve du pentathlon sur
les arts du château de Versailles nous
gagnons ou encore imaginer une chanson
sur une mélodie du 17e siècle
environ 3000 collégiens des Yvelines et
des Hauts-de-Seine ont pu découvrir le
château de Versailles différemment grâce
à des ateliers pédagogiques c'est en
même temps culturel et en même temps
amusant moi j'aime bien parce qu'en fait
on fait plusieurs activités aussi donc
on peut pas on s'ennuie pas et on fait
on apprend des choses
[Musique]
musique art de la Seine concert cette
année pour les établissements scolaires
cette journée s'inscrit dans le projet
Pentathlon des arts cette année le
pentathlon des arts pouvait toucher
plusieurs professeurs du collège et
notamment l'atelier théâtre c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi d'emmener ses
élèves là aujourd'hui participer à cette
journée découvrir un petit peu le
château sous un autre angle c'est pas la
première fois qu'on participe au projet
et tout simplement pour leur faire
découvrir déjà le parc du château le
château de Versailles je commence à
parsoit au final ils viennent pas
toujours mais malgré qu'il soit
facilement que ça cette initiative est
portée par les départements des Yvelines
et des Hauts-de-Seine en partenariat
avec le château de Versailles depuis
2019 pour beaucoup c'était une première
il n'était jamais venu visiter la
demeure de Louis XIV
allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une page
cinéma présent
comme tous les mercredis on fait le
point sur les films à ne pas manquer
cette semaine au cinéma c'est avec vous
Céline Charles et on commence ce soir
avec un peu de romantisme et oui
Mathilde alors si vous adorez Love
Actually coup de foudre à Notting Hill
ou encore la la Land et bien je vous
propose cette semaine love again c'est
la nouvelle comédie romantique qu'on
aime regarder sous un plaid avec un
chocolat chaud alors pour vous mettre en
haleine love again c'est déjà un casting
aux petits oignons on retrouve Priyanka
Chopra ça me gagne et le film c'est même
offert les services de Céline Dion la
star fait ses premiers pas au cinéma
c'est d'ailleurs elle qui signe une
bonne partie de la bande-son du film
pour ce qui est de l'histoire c'est
toujours très romanesque mira est une
femme endeuillée par la mort de son
petit ami et pour surmonter ce décès
elle va envoyer des textos au
quotidiennement à son ancien numéro
histoire de lui raconter ses journées et
de se sentir moins seul petit bémol
qu'elle ignore ce numéro a depuis été
attribué au nouveau téléphone
professionnel de robe un journaliste
chargé de rédiger le portrait de la star
Céline Dion captivé par la sincérité des
messages qu'il reçoit il va peu à peu
tomber amoureux regarder un extrait de
la bande-annonce tu crois qu'on peut
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un uniquement
par ces mots je te trouve très mignon
[Applaudissements]
plus je la découvre plus elle me plaît
[Musique]
plein de choses ne se produit pas juste
comme ça l'amour a un plan pour chacun
d'entre nous
[Musique]
et bien sûr et moi je suis Mariah Carey
en tout cas ça donne envie d'aller voir
Céline Dion au cinéma Céline vous nous
proposez un autre rendez-vous c'est un
biopic sur Marinette Pichon oui pour
ceux qui ne la connais pas Marinette
Pichon c'est une footballeuse
internationale française c'est
d'ailleurs la première footballeuse
française professionnelle son parcours
et son nom sont encore assez méconnus et
pourtant son histoire est
impressionnante jusqu'en 2020 elle
détenait le record du nombre de buts
marqués sous le maillot bleu homme et
femme confondus alors passionné depuis
toute petite par le foot elle a sûrement
elle a dû surmonter de multiples
difficultés avant d'arriver au sommet un
père violent le sexisme dans le milieu
sportif la compétition entre les
joueuses son homosexualité le film
retrace vraiment tout de son enfance à
sa retraite de joueuse en 2007 c'est un
film sur une battante qui traite aussi
beaucoup du sujet de l'égalité
homme-femme dans le sport regardez
[Musique]
Coupe du Monde il y a plus aucune
défaite tout à construire encore pour le
football féminin en France comment vous
voulez qu'on fasse le poivre alors que
nous on est même pas payé
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est tout donné au football
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais vu une chose comme ça
[Musique]
et on termine votre sélection Céline par
le nouveau Transformers oui c'est déjà
le 7e film de la saga dont l'histoire
suit les Transformers ces robots venus
de l'espace capable de se changer en
véhicule alors dans ce nouveau film les
protagonistes vont se retrouver plongés
au milieu des années 1990 les Autobots
se vont devoir affronter un nouveau
groupe d'ennemis les terrorcons ils
feront également la rencontre des
maximes des Transformers qui se changent
en animaux et dans leur aventures ils
vont embarquer deux héros humains cette
fois-ci Noah a un ancien militaire en
quête d'argent et Elena chercheuse dans
un musée tous vont chercher une clé
intersidérale convoitée également par la
Ligue ennemi merci beaucoup c'est ninja
alors habituel petit tour de plateau
quelle est votre film préféré on
commence par vous peut-être moi je vais
partir sur la comédie romantique je suis
vraiment ça m'étonne un peu de veau
j'ai l'impression que vous préférez
quand même les films d'horreur les noms
ça dépend de la saison c'est pas pour
l'hiver j'aime bien c'est vrai que là on
arrive en une petite commande comédie
romantique ça fait toujours du bien
c'est une histoire de mood avec Céline
Dion c'est ça la bande-son est tellement
tellement chouette que vous êtes une
grande fan d'ici là c'est ça Sylvie
desclèvent une préférence ah ben moi ce
sera aussi la comédie romantique j'adore
ces moments passés c'est notre film de
Noël souvent moi j'ai hâte de voir
Céline Dion à l'écran en tout cas et vos
régime pour changer enfin pour ne pas
changer je dirais que oui la comédie
romantique aussi donc je pense que c'est
une très bonne vendeuse parce que j'aime
pas trop les comédies romantiques mais
là j'ai vraiment envie d'y aller et
Marinette Pichon elle a vraiment bien
aussi je pense que c'est intéressant
comme histoire donc mon coeur balance
entre les deux donc je vais voir les
réalisatrices du film grave aussi qui
avait été très très reconnu à l'époque
merci beaucoup Céline Charles c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission depuis
la scène du prisme d'Élancourt mais
avant je vous propose de jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
demain matin le soleil sera bien au
rendez-vous dans les Yvelines côté
température ça grimpe compter 19 degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Versailles
et 18 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi il fera toujours beau temps
au niveau des températures il fera en
moyenne 26 à 27 degrés et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité à 20h30 ne manquez pas entracte
la soirée de lancement de la nouvelle
saison culturelle au Théâtre du prisme à
Élancourt elle sera retransmise sur
notre antenne je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]